well now to a major development in the
police killing of brianna taylor the 26
year old black woman was shot to death
more than two years ago in a mistaken
raid on the apartment in louisville
where she was sleeping four of the
officers involved now face federal
charges in the case senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is at
the justice department catherine good
morning
good morning michelle the justice
department is investigating whether
brianna taylor's death is part of a
broad pattern and practice of misconduct
within the louisville police department
as the attorney general released the
charges yesterday
brianna taylor should be alive today
attorney general merrick garland
announced the civil rights charges in
the botched raid that killed 26 year old
brianna taylor the four current and
former officers are accused of crimes
that include obstruction falsifying an
affidavit to secure a search warrant and
excessive use of force
on march 13 2020 louisville police
officers raided taylor's apartment
searching for drugs allegedly stashed by
a former boyfriend kenneth walker a
different man who was in the apartment
and dating taylor at the time fired one
shot at police from a gun he was
licensed to carry my girlfriend
louisville police officers fired more
than 30 shots many blindly into the
apartment taylor was struck and killed
in an interview with gail king walker
said the police never identified
themselves they'd knock on the door and
say who it was we could we can hear them
it's dead silent i know a million
percent sure that nobody identified
themselves
i've waited
874 days
for today taylor's mother tamika palmer
spoke to reporters along with family
attorney ben crump because of brianna
taylor
we can say this is a day
that black women saw equal justice in
the united states of america
sergeant kyle meaney and former
detective joshua james are charged with
falsifying an affidavit to obtain the
raid search warrant former detective
brent henkerson is charged with blindly
firing into taylor's apartment jane's
and detective kelly goodlett are accused
of covering up their actions
brianna taylor's death during the
botched police raid galvanized the
social justice movement her name is now
synonymous with demonstrations over
policing and racial injustice rihanna
taylor should have awakened in her home
as usual on the morning of march
thirteenth two thousand twenty
tragically she did not
brett hankinson and joshua james have
been fired the louisville police
department is in the process of
terminating kyle meaney and kelly
goodlett at yesterday's news conference
the attorney general would not comment
on whether the recent acquittal of one
defendant on state charges could
negatively impact the federal case nate
catherine thank you